[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 184 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Mark.
And today I'm here with Mark.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey, Mark.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I have
a cold so I'm at home
and my house is falling apart.
[OBJECTS FALLING AND GLASS
BREAKING]
But outside of that,
I'm doing well.
How are you doing?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You know, I
like your positive attitude,
which is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thanks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
But that sounds bad.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
It's fine.
Everything will be
fine eventually.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It all works out.
MARK MANDEL: After a while.
But we have a great
interview today.
Gabi and I did an
interview with Informatica
with Bill Creekbaum--
Senior Director of
Product Management
for Cloud, Big Data,
and Athletic Ecosystems
at Informatica.
Whew, that is a long title.
I hope one day I have
a title that long.
But we talk all
about hybrid cloud
with big data and analytics,
migrations from primitive cloud
with big data and analytics.
Also, some good stuff
around, essentially,
big data and analytics.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
that sounds pretty exciting.
And I think that if
you tried hard enough,
you could probably just
insert more Google products
into your title.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think so.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Master of
Agones and Kubernetes and Data
Flow and BigQuery and
also Consultant on--
and you could just keep going.
MARK MANDEL: Then I'd have
to learn a lot more products
than I currently know.
And that sounds hard.
And I don't feel
like doing that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, in order
to test your knowledge there,
I have a great question
of the week for you, which
talks a little bit about
App Engine and using custom
domains.
But before we even--
MARK MANDEL: Ooh--
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
-- get into that--
MARK MANDEL: --that
sounds like fun.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: -- we should
talk about our cool things
of the week.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: We
absolutely should.
First of all, let me say a large
congratulations to Chronicle.
If you aren't familiar
with Chronicle,
they are the security
moonshot company inside Google
that deal with all kinds of
interesting security stuff.
You may have heard the
episode we did previously,
135, talking about that
one of their things,
which is VirusTotal,
which is actually
a free scanner for files
for malware and viruses.
It can also be
used by companies.
It's very, very cool.
And it's just one of the things
they do in the security space.
But pretty excited to have
them on board with Google Cloud
to help enhance the
security features
we have with Google Cloud and
make all the security things
better for all our customers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, I
mean, that sounds awesome.
And I think that, it's not
as though people aren't
concerned about security.
And we talk a lot
about encryption
and all the kind of different
infrastructure level security
offerings that Google
Cloud has by default.
But for larger companies,
you need more, right?
You need virus protection, email
protection, all those things.
So I think that them joining
Google Cloud will really
open up some real cool
opportunities for people who
use the Cloud one
of the cool things
that I was actually
just recently reading,
is that we are opening
a new undersea cable--
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--to, I think, it's
right around the
west coast of Africa.
So it goes all the
way from Europe
all the way down to
the bottom of Africa.
In case you weren't aware,
Africa is a very big continent,
so that's going
to be a big cable.
I just think it's fascinating.
When I joined Google there
were a lot of people making
jokes about the undersea cables
and the shark proofing, which
apparently is a
real thing, right?
[LAUGHS] And for anyone
who hasn't heard of it,
we had these big
undersea cables--
MARK MANDEL: It's a
thing. it's a real thing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: --that
go around the globe.
And a common problem,
apparently, with those cables
is that sharks like to eat them.
[CHOMPING] Which I can't
relate to, I have to say.
MARK MANDEL: I
believe it actually
has something to do with the
electronics going through it
and it sets off their sensors
and they like really like--
I don't know exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, I should
do some research on that.
That sounds really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
But for the people
who are trying to get
internet through those wires,
it turns out sharks are
kind of a [BLEEP] pain.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Generally speaking,
people chewing through
your cables is a bad thing.
Anyway, I think
it's really awesome.
And it just fascinates
me that we're just
building these huge
pipelines to just add
additional connectivity for
a lot of different areas.
So I'm really excited
to see this one come
online in the next two years.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
And shout out to all
the listeners in Africa.
Hopefully this works
out very well for you.
All right, cool.
So I think I have
something else as well.
Oh, yes.
I would be remiss if I
didn't mention Kubernetes
at least once in a podcast.
So this was a little bit
ago, but I don't think
it's been mentioned so far.
Kubernetes 115, congratulations
to the team on that release.
I'm pretty excited about this.
This is a lot of extensibility
around core Kubernetes API-- as
including custom resource
definitions and a lot
of new features for custom
resource definitions,
which is an area
which I work in a lot.
So very excited about that.
As well as cluster lifecycle
stability and usability
improvements, container
storage, functionality,
and lots of other good
things there as well.
So if you want to
dig more into that,
there's actually a
really good article
that we'll link
to as well talking
about the future of customer
resource definitions, which
they're calling
"structural schemas."
That's a lot of alliteration.
Where they go into
that a lot deeper
and I'm pretty excited about it.
It looks like it's going
to be really, really
handy for those people who
write controllers and operators.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You know,
there's a been, obviously,
a lot of recent news
around Kubernetes.
And then somewhat
related is Istio,
of course, which I think just
relaunched 2 or 1.12 recently.
I should know that.
But I think it's super cool
to see all these updates.
I'm seeing a lot of stuff on
the internet about people being
scared about Kubernetes
kind of adding
too many features into that.
So I'm really interested to
see how the community is really
driving a lot of the
upgrades and different things
that go into each
Kubernetes release.
MARK MANDEL: It's Istio 1.2.
I checked that out for you.
This could be a whole
episode in and of itself.
I think there's
two things to that.
I think there's a lot of
stuff that you can just
do with Kubernetes, like
services and deployments.
And that's it.
Like you could just
get started with that.
You can get running.
But I think all the
extension mechanisms
mean that people can
build simpler layers even,
or highly opinionated
layers going forward,
as well, to make things easier
for very specific workloads.
So I think there's a two
pronged approach there.
But yeah, that could
almost be its own episode.
That sounds like it might
be a good episode, actually.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, actually,
now that you mention it, why
don't we do that episode?
MARK MANDEL: We should
do that episode.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right,
we'll make a note and do that.
[TYPEWRITER CLICKING]
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But let's
finish this one first.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
have one more cool thing
of the week, which is now that
Stackdriver Profiler is now
generally available.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, fancy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: This was a
really cool tool that I think
was in beta for quite a while.
But it actually lets you look
at production code that's
executing and then see
how it's performing
as it traces through, as
different functions are
being called.
And it kind of gives you
this cool little visual stack
of where your time
is being spent.
So for a lot of the people
who use Stackdriver--
and a lot of people
who, actually, say,
who are using production
code on GCP, Stackdriver
has been a really
awesome tool because it
lets you do live of code
debugging and fixing
in production.
MARK MANDEL: Mmm.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Which
is super impress-- well,
probably not fixing,
but actual observation
and seeing like, oh, well.
You know, sometimes
in dev, you just
can't reproduce that problem.
So being able to
reproduce it in production
and then having a really
clear visual graph
of where those slowdowns are
and where the problem might be--
I think that's super awesome.
And so now that it's GA I think,
hopefully, a lot more people
will be more comfortable
trying it out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that
sounds really great.
Fantastic.
Well, I tell you what, why don't
we get stuck into the interview
that Gabi and I did with
Bill from Informatica
and we can hear
all about big data
and analytics and, all
sorts of other fun things.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Cool,
excited to hear it.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
very happy today
to have Bill Creekbaum here--
Senior Director of Product
Management Cloud and Big Data
Ecosystems from Informatica.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot.
Bill, how are you doing today?
BILL CREEKBAUM: I'm doing great.
Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so
much for joining us today.
Before we get stuck into
some big data things
and talking a little bit
about Informatica as well,
that is a really
big product title.
So who are you?
What do you do?
What's it all about?
BILL CREEKBAUM: So
I have the privilege
of working with the
cloud, big data,
and analytics ecosystems
for Informatica.
And a lot of our customers
would think, especially
in the context of Google,
that means we really
focus on connectivity to
BigQuery and Google Cloud
Storage.
But we actually have a
much broader charter.
I'm really focused on making
sure that all of our products
take the most advantage of the
strengths of the Google Cloud
Platform.
So for example, we have a
big data management product
that allows customers to
visually build and manage
big data jobs that integrate
with all our governance
tools and what not.
An option that we have, through
the partnership with Google,
is we allow the customers
to design in Informatica
and push the job
down to dataproc.
So it actually runs as
a push down job there.
And we can do similar
chemicals with BigQuery.
More recently, we have really
done a lot of partnership
with Google to create
value added solutions
for our [? common ?] customers.
And it's far more than
just connectivity,
now where we're thinking about
broad use cases, customer
360 type use cases,
marketing use cases.
It's very exciting.
MARK MANDEL: So you
said a lot of words
that I'm going to guess
relate to big data and stuff.
But why don't we
start at a high level.
So what is Informatica
actually do?
BILL CREEKBAUM: Informatica
provides a portfolio
of data management products.
All of our products are
very metadata aware,
and the benefit there is by
having a complete solution that
focuses on integration,
governance, security, data
quality, and discoverability--
you have that completely
integrated solution
that allows you to move
quickly, move safely, deal
with strict regulations
with confidence.
At the same time, deliver
business value, right?
I mean, everyone talks about
the democratization of data,
this is how you do it.
If you're missing any
one of those pieces then
you're starting to worry.
You open yourselves
up to risk and then
that's when you start
to hold the data back.
And so I think
with our platform,
we really allow business users
to get a hold of the data.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So what's a really
great example of someone
using Informatica and
Google Cloud together
that people might--
like what would be a
canonical example of that?
BILL CREEKBAUM: There's a
couple of really good examples.
I think a lot of what I've been
really excited to see recently
is customers that try to
build like a customer 360
type analytical solutions.
And they started on-prem,
they started using [INAUDIBLE]
and that was really a lot of
the promise of the beginning
of the big data movement.
But the operational costs
are just so extreme.
But now they're working
with Google and BigQuery
in particular, and
they're just seeing
so much tremendous
opportunity to move
those very expensive workloads
on-prem into the cloud.
They're saving a ton of money.
But more importantly, they're
seeing new opportunities.
The technology is opening
doors to new use cases.
And I think that's my favorite
part, is customers begin
the journey as
like, oh, it's going
to be cheaper for me
to run it in the cloud.
And then they pause and they
go like, Wait, wait, wait.
You mean, I can do it
completely different and faster
and still do it cheaper?
That's when you start to see
the creativity of our customers
in our industry at large,
really take flight.
GABI FERRARA: So Informatica,
from what I got it,
you were able to facilitate
ETL processing for customers.
Let's say you let them
build their own pipelines,
apparently.
And beyond that, how the
customers approach you?
You said that some already
have an old set up already
from the beginning of big data.
But how usually a
new company comes
to you that has no
big data at all,
they want to start doing it--
how does that approach happen?
BILL CREEKBAUM:
Well, it definitely
depends on where that
particular customer is
in their-- let's call it the
modernization journey, right?
But what we've been
really excited to see
is that, when our customers
use our complete portfolio, not
just our integration products
but the complete portfolio,
especially with our metadata
driven catalog capabilities.
Because they start much more
from a use case perspective,
they start from a business
object perspective.
Because first of all, you got
to find the right data, right?
You might have a sales
operation use case, right?
And you're working
with sales ops.
You want to
modernize, let's say,
a marketing lead campaign
initiative, right?
Well, to start, "I got to find
good marketing lead data."
And so if I have a catalog that
has scanning my enterprise,
I can type in the Google
for the enterprise, right?
Show me all my
marketing lead data.
And you might get back 20, 30,
maybe 50 different data assets.
At that point, OK, I'm
overwhelmed as a business user.
"So do I just pick
the one at the top?
Do it randomly pick?
How do I choose?"
And what's really
beneficial is that when
you have that data catalog
capability with a higher order
value--
use machine learning to identify
business objects, locate PII.
You can start to make some
really intelligent decisions.
Because now I can determine,
this says marketing lead.
Does it have all
the elements that's
required for a complete
marketing lead object?
So that's step one.
And then step two
is, "do I know where
that data came
from and do I know
if it's being used
downstream and
by a different application?"
So for example, if I see
a marketing lead object
and I see that that object
is being populated by Marketo
and Salesforce sources, right?
Those are pretty reliable
industry sources.
And I see it being consumed by
10 downstream applications that
says, wow, this is actually
being used by the business.
I can safely assume that this
object is valuable and trusted.
Whereas, if I compare it
with another object that
has no downstream
consumption, I can
make some informed decisions
on which data to begin using.
So the point is, is by combining
data discovery with data
integration, you can make
much better decisions
about what data to integrate.
And then go straight into
the provisioning process
to BigQuery.
GABI FERRARA: I usually see
people saying, and I agree,
that [? the business file ?]
relies on the quality of data
that you have.
It doesn't matter how much money
you're bringing, if you're not
creating your data
properly, you're
going to have some
troubles, especially
if you want to modernize.
Do data analytics,
do machine learning,
you need to rely on your source.
And do you encounter
a lot of people
having problems with data that's
not normalized, duplicated
records?
Let's say, do you
have that many issues
and do you help those customers
solve this kind of issues
too or not?
BILL CREEKBAUM: Absolutely.
I've been in the analytics
space for the better
part of the past decade and
I've seen so many analytics
initiatives fail after such
great intentions because
of bad quality data.
It has nothing to do with
the analytics itself,
it has to do with bad
raw material, right?
And the quality data
comes from a couple
of different scenarios.
Number one is, is it safe
for me to access, right?
If I can't safely access
the data, there's no point.
At that point quality
doesn't matter.
So having a solution that masks
data or adheres to role-based
access controls--
number one, I mean, that allows
a business user to safely
use the data, right?
And we all talk about
enabling the citizen x, right?
Citizen integrators, citizen
application developers,
citizen analysts.
We want those business users
to safely acquire them.
So once your platform has
allowed them to safely acquire
the data, what is the quality?
And quality is completeness
of data, right?
If I've got a data set that's
got a bunch of null values,
that's going to have
limited utility for me.
And being able to really
profile your data set
gives me an understanding
of the quality of data.
But beyond that, now we get into
a higher order of data quality.
And so let's continue our
marketing lead example.
If I've got a table with
really good marketing lead
object definitions and part of
that is email addresses, phone
numbers, and zip codes, yet
60% of my email addresses
are malformed and my zip
codes only have three digits--
yeah, the structure
might look fantastic,
but the actual data is going
to be useless for me, right?
And you don't want
to throw it away.
Do you have the ability
to recover from it
and get quality data?
And if not, can we
safely exclude the data?
So it's absolutely essential
because at the end of the day,
analytics comes down to,
do you trust the output?
And the higher the quality
input, the better trust you
have with a particular analytic.
MARK MANDEL: Given that we
are the Google Cloud Platform
podcast, this all
sounds really great.
But in application, what
tools and products are we
using here on Google Cloud to
help facilitate this pipeline?
BILL CREEKBAUM:
Well, our customers
is a combination of both our
company's products, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
BILL CREEKBAUM: And so,
from Informatica's side,
they're using our
intelligent cloud services,
they're using our enterprise
data catalog, big data
management, and sometimes
security source, which
is one of our governance tools.
And then on the Google Cloud
Platform side, Google BigQuery.
I mean, I'm telling you guys, I
am seeing so much traffic flow
through to BigQuery.
And the adoption is fantastic.
And I'm seeing huge
curves up and to the right
on adoption and usage.
But to really
complement BigQuery,
there's a lot of usage
of Google Cloud Storage.
That makes less sense.
I mean, behind the covers, we
use [? it a lot ?] in tandem
to really drive performance
of bulk loading.
We also see a lot
of inner operation
with Google Analytics.
And we're starting to see a much
bigger uptake of technologies
like Pub/Sub as part
of these workflows.
And I already talked
about Dataproc earlier.
So one of things that I
think about a great deal,
and that my entire
team thinks about
is, how can we best
provide our customers
with the strengths of BigQuery
and the entire Google Cloud
platform surfaced through the
Informatica products, right?
Because I want to give
them easy access to it.
That's what Informatica
brings to the table, right?
We bring the easy access,
visual design environments,
governance, lineage, metadata
management, et cetera.
But I don't want to provide
coverage that's just like,
vanilla access.
I want our customers
to take the most
advantage of why
they picked Google
Cloud in the first place.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Do you have customers
that are like,
"hey, I've already got
a Google Cloud project
and I've got a bunch of stuff
to Google Cloud storage."
And they come to you and they're
like, "we're already doing
stuff, how do we integrate?"
Or do you find it's
coming from the other way
where you've got
customers for Informatica,
and they're like,
"oh, actually now
we want to push this
down into Google Cloud
in some way, shape, or form."
BILL CREEKBAUM: I got to
tell you, Mark, sometimes I
feel like it's coming from
top, bottom, left, and right.
[LAUGHS]
And all different combinations.
But in all seriousness,
I mean, we really
focus on the hybrid
enterprise, right?
And there's just crazy
momentum to the cloud.
I mean, heck, I've been talking
about it ever since the cloud
was born, right?
But it is just happening
with fierce velocity.
But no matter that
velocity, large enterprises
are still going to have
a presence on-prem.
And we have to treat that
hybrid nature of on-prem, cloud,
multi-cloud as first
class citizens.
We all do.
So a lot of times
our customers will--
I hate to speak in generalities,
but from anecdotal engagements
and evidence, a lot
of our customers
we'll start with, "I need
to modernize my warehouse
and I want to get
into BigQuery."
Great cost, performance,
benefits, great technology.
And they start off with really
just more of a cost savings.
They want to get rid of their
physical infrastructure,
shift the operation
load to Google.
But the reality is that
halfway through that journey,
that light, that
epiphany happens.
They start to see much more the
value add of what can be done.
For example, I was engaging
with a large joint customer
earlier in the year,
and their initial goal
was just to modernize their
warehouse with BigQuery.
We started down that path
and it was going really well.
And actually during
a joint engagement
where I was actually
co-presenting with somebody
from Google to this particular
customer, the light went on
and they're going,
"wait, wait wait.
Can I replace my Hadoop
environment on-prem
with BigQuery and actually
unify all my data?"
You should have seen the grins.
It was like this
collective room of lights
going on about
what was possible.
The art of the possible.
So back to your point, Mark,
coming from existing scenarios
or new scenarios--
a lot of times
they'll come with a
new initiative but then
all of a sudden, it'll blossom
into multiple initiatives
happening at once.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm glad
you brought up on-prem
because I wanted to ask you
about that data migration
story.
How are you seeing
customers taking their data
and bringing it from, say
an on-prem environment
and bringing it into the cloud?
I mean, that seems like a
big job in and of itself.
BILL CREEKBAUM: It is a
And there are
technical nuances that
need to be considered, right?
The one that I run
into most often
are differences in
data types, right?
But what I see a
lot of customers
start with is just
like-- again, they
see dollar signs and the
opportunity for immediate cost
savings.
And that's absolutely correct.
I mean, there can be a
tremendous and fast ROY
by moving from a legacy
warehouse into BigQuery.
And what that means
is that, customers
are oftentimes starting
with like a lift and shift.
I just want take what
there, move it into BigQuery
and be done.
And it's true, a
customer can realize
some quick savings that way.
But so much is lost.
And if you're going to
go through this effort--
and let's be honest,
this is an effort.
No matter how much awesome
tooling both of our companies
bring to the table,
it's still an effort.
Customers that don't
take this inflection
point to think
about the future, I
think are missing a great
deal of opportunity.
I think the obvious example
is classic warehouse models
are heavily normalized,
which made a lot of sense
for the classic warehouse
based on old technologies,
old storage, old
compute and whatnot.
But we all know that
when you move to BigQuery
it's like, no, no.
Well, seriously, to
normalize is to really take
advantage of the power.
But it's such a complete
shift for DBAs and people
that have been doing
this for 25 to 30 years.
And for those that
just simply do
a lift and shift for that
immediate cost savings,
I think they're really
missing a great opportunity.
And so a lot of times we'll
start off with the lift
and shift to get
immediate success.
But then it immediately
moves into an evolution
once you're in BigQuery
to start taking
advantage of the data
structures and technologies that
are there.
So it's not an either/or, but
it's a closely synchronous
and, if you will.
It goes lift and shift
immediately into evolution.
And that's where I think we
see a lot of benefits gained.
GABI FERRARA: I
remember when I started
working with a bit of big
data, I'm not that versed.
Let's say that the fact of
being able to use BigQuery, just
put my data there and
it figure out indexes,
it figure out how many
servers it's going
to take to spin off a query--
that probably makes your
product more versatile
taking advantage of
this kind of technology.
And you said this mind
shift for old school DBAs
still has growing pains.
Does that happen to you too?
BILL CREEKBAUM:
It certainly does.
And I think,
especially customers
that have been working with
Informatica for 20, 25 years,
there's a familiarity
with the common patterns.
But sometimes those
common patterns
don't translate
well into the cloud
and so there's a learning curve.
And I think one of the
things that Informatica
is able to bring to the
table is that we help
flatten that learning curve.
We can help take advantage
of the unique capabilities
of the cloud faster because
from our customer's perspective,
they're still working with
this familiar toolset.
And yes, the technology behind
that we're connecting to
differs.
But we're able to
abstract it, so we're
able to get some
really fast adoption.
But once you do that
fast adoption-- remember,
a few moments go I was
talking about we also
want to make sure that
the customers can truly
take advantage of the
characteristics of Google Cloud
Platform in BigQuery.
So for example, we
talked about ETL earlier
but let's talk about ELT,
extract load transform.
We want to seriously
take advantage
of that kind of
capability in BigQuery.
So using our intelligent
cloud services
to actually load
data into BigQuery
and then process
the transformation
inside BigQuery-- we're
able to actually push down
the entire job into
BigQuery so that we're
using the BigQuery engine to
do all the transformations.
And that's got a
couple of benefits.
Number one, you
just talked about.
It's a serverless
scale out environment
with tremendous compute
power that you're
able to spin up on demand.
That means Informatica is able
to take advantage of that.
And so we're able to deliver
a crazy amount of performance
with ease.
And our common customers are
benefiting greatly from that.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
I'm kind of curious
as well too, obviously
you've worked with a variety
of people who do these big data
and analytics platforms.
If you could tell anyone who
works in big data and analytics
one thing that they
should all be doing
or one mistake they should
potentially not make?
That's broadly generalized.
What would you suggest as maybe
the best practice you would
love to get out into the world?
BILL CREEKBAUM: Oh, Mark,
that's such a loaded question.
MARK MANDEL: That's
why I asked it.
BILL CREEKBAUM: Can't
I have like 10 not one?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we
can give it a couple.
We've got some time.
BILL CREEKBAUM: I think
I'd probably boil it down
into three very distinct
recommendations.
Number one is, you've got to
take stock of what you've got.
I think companies are
completely surprised
by the amount of data assets
that they have in every nook
and cranny of their enterprise.
And you really want to take
a good inventory of what
you have, determine what's
important, prioritizing,
and categories.
That's kind of step one.
But maybe most importantly,
you need to set goals.
And I know that sounds
basic and it sounds obvious,
but more often than not, I'm
not seeing clear goals set.
So A, we have no
idea when we ever
finish because we don't
know where we're headed.
And when we do get
there, was it successful?
Was it not?
We don't know.
And by setting
goals, you set focus.
You set your guiding star that
everyone aligns and marches
towards.
Which then leads into the
third one and that is,
you've got to develop a team.
And again, it seems obvious
but maybe not in the way
that you're thinking about it.
I would recommend companies
to form a migration SWAT team.
And this is a team that is well
versed both in the technology
and the business goals.
Because they need to
be the leaders, right?
Because they're going to need
to get people to follow them
on this journey into the cloud.
And for many people,
especially those
that are comfortable with
the familiarity of doing
it the old way, they're
going to ask why.
And you want this team to
be able to not only execute,
but to also inspire the
confidence in moving
to the cloud.
And so when you combine
that with clear goals
and a really good
understanding of what
you have in place today, I just
think it sets an enterprise up
for success.
GABI FERRARA: Talking
about innovations
and easy to use technologies
is good, but also brings up,
with great powers, greater
responsibilities, right?
[LAUGH TRACK]
So how does GDPR and
those kind of regulations
ensure they're working
with Informatica?
Because one thing
is to be GDPR ready,
and then thing to
be GDPR compliant.
BILL CREEKBAUM: Absolutely.
GABI FERRARA: You know?
So how do you deal with that?
BILL CREEKBAUM:
Well, again, I don't
want to sound like
a broken record,
but because we deliver a
platform that integrates
integration, governance,
security, metadata management,
discovery as part of
the whole platform,
it's a little bit
easier for us to deliver
on the realization of being
GDPR compliant, not just ready.
For example, the
right to be forgotten.
It's a difficult problem, right?
I mean, if you think
like a global enterprise
with many subsidiaries,
you probably
have PIIs sitting all
over the globe managed
by many different
business units.
But the right to be forgotten
doesn't care about such silos.
It's like, if I want to
be forgotten, that's it.
You need it forget me.
And so we have a product that's
called Secure Source that
allows a compliance
officer to log in
and actually says, show
me on all the locations
within my enterprise
where PII exists.
And then from there,
again, it's like, OK.
I have a road map
of where I need
to go so that when somebody
chooses to be forgotten,
I'm not guessing or hoping.
I'm able to know.
And it's definitely
one of the benefits
of having that unified
platform that's
integrated as a
complete solution
because it enables that.
And things like GDPR and CCPA--
I mean, they codify much of
what we've talked about, right?
We've talked about
security and governance
since we've began our
conversation a short while ago.
And this kind of codifies
the requirements.
But I think in some
sense, every enterprise
worries about this
regardless of regulation.
MARK MANDEL: Speaking of things
like personally identifiable
information and other potential
high-risk information storage,
do you have best practices
or things that people should
be aware of when looking
at that kind of data that
could potentially be high-risk?
BILL CREEKBAUM: Absolutely.
I mean, we started off talking
about modernizing your data
infrastructure to BigQuery.
So let's look at it from the
construct of that journey,
right?
And we talked about setting
goals and building a team
to be successful.
Well, part of being
successful also quick wins.
You want to build momentum
based off of success.
So one of things that I've
seen successful companies do
is when they start their
migrations into the cloud,
let's not start off with
the tables full of PII
because that
radically complicates
the scenario because now you got
to get your IT people involved,
you get your security
people involved,
you get the governance
people involved.
So sometimes it's best to know
where your PII data is not,
right?
And so, by using
your data catalog,
by using Informatica's
data catalog,
you can see and not guess.
It's like, OK, this
table's got a bunch of PII.
It's a lot of value here.
But you know what,
let's do that maybe
in phase two or phase three.
Let's come and take a look
these other data objects
that has a lot of
business value below PII.
And that's going to allow me
to migrate to BigQuery rapidly,
get success, build a new use
case, and now I can repeat.
And build on that success
and gain that momentum.
Probably almost like
the opposite answer
what you expected expecting
but sometimes knowing
where your PII is not
is very beneficial.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, cool.
So we're coming up on
time here, unfortunately.
But before we go,
Bill, is there anything
that we've missed or you
want to mention or make sure
that you get out there
so people can hear it?
BILL CREEKBAUM: You know, Mark,
so number one, thanks to you
and Gabi.
I've had a great time
chatting with you both.
Yeah, I would say that to our
customers listening today,
check out the partnership
between our companies.
It's fantastic.
I truly enjoy working
with the team at Google
and together we're doing
some great solutions
for our customers.
And it's fun to be in
market with you guys.
So thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, thanks for being
a wonderful partner.
Well, Bill, thank you so
much for joining us today
on the podcast.
BILL CREEKBAUM: My
pleasure, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Huge thanks
to Bill for joining
Gabi and I this week.
Super interesting episode.
Really, I don't do a lot
with big data analytics,
so it was super handy
for me to learn more
about that area and some
of the migration patterns
that people have.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Plus,
I feel like if you
do some more in that area, then
you can add that to your title.
MARK MANDEL: Sure, yeah.
Then I can have a
long title like Bill.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
more relevant to I
think everyone who's
listening than your title,
I think we have our
question of the week.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Yes we do.
Go ahead, ask it.
I'm ready.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So when
you create an App Engine app,
you get a domain
that comes with it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Usually
a pretty generic domain
based on the project
name and then App Engine.
But of course, you can use
your own custom domains.
And I think a lot
of people, they
want to do that because
custom domains are nice.
But when you're using a
custom domain, sometimes
a lot of times you
need to use subdomains.
How the heck do
you use subdomains
with a custom domain
in App Engine?
MARK MANDEL: Whoo.
That's a good question.
So there is actually a
lot of really cool ways
you can configure
subdomains with App
Engine in both static
and dynamic ways,
which is super nice.
So for a static point of view,
you can set up a dispatch.yaml.
It's a configuration file
wherein you can configure,
actually, a variety of stuff.
Not only just
subdomains, but also
pods and some other things
to particular services.
So services are individual
deployments inside App Engine.
Like if you had
different APIs endpoints,
you might want to do
different services.
Then you can have versions
within those services as well.
So you can set that up within
your dispatch.yaml to say
like, oh, I want
[? dog.food.bar ?] I
want that dot com to go
to my default service.
But [? cat.food.bar ?] I
want to go to my cat service.
And that's pretty
straightforward.
It's just a yaml file and
it is pretty easy to setup.
That being said, if you
want to get dynamic with it,
which some people do.
We use it for some things
and it might be a bit easier.
You can set that up
with Wild Cards as well.
So you can do that
to the lower level
down in your dispatch.yaml.
But if you just want
to do it simply,
you don't even need
a dispatch.yaml.
You can set up
your custom domain
with, basically, a Wild Card.
So you might be like
[? star.food.com ?]
and you can set that up in your
custom domain configuration.
And then potentially also
have a Wild Card for your SSL
if you have an SSL, which
you probably should.
And what's nice there
is what will happen
there is if a person goes to
a subdomain, writes a Wild
Card-- could be any
subdomain, App Engine
will actually look for a
version or a service that
matches the same name
as that subdomain.
If you go to a
[? dog.food.com, ?] it will go
look for a service named "dog"
and it will then serve that.
So that be a really handy
way if you have subdomains
that come up on a
regular basis, maybe
you have snapshots
of documentation
that you want
[INAUDIBLE] version,
something like that, that
come up every regular period.
You can set up something
dynamic like that
so that all you have to do is
create a new either version
or service that matches
the subdomain that you have
and then that'll get served.
And if App Engine can't
find that subdomain
it will just send it back to
default, which is fine too.
So you can do some really nice
dynamic stuff that way too.
So you have lots of options.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So if
you have the Wild Card,
you obviously get all
the subdomains you want.
And then from there, you
can either statically
configure them, saying
which ones you want.
Or you can do it
dynamically and then pull up
different versions, which I
think you made a great use
case for when you said,
hey, you might have
different versions
that are in the past
and you want to still
have references to those.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So you
kind of have two great ways
to continue hosting content
all from a single App Engine
project.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and it's
kind of like that whole thing
where it's, convention
for configuration--
you know one way,
with the Wild Cards.
Or you can have
static configuration
using your dispatch.yaml.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
Well, I think that should
help a lot of people
who are looking to make more
complex App Engine deployments.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, before we wrap up,
Mark, are you going anywhere?
Doing any cool content?
Or are you working on
anything you can talk about it
or is it all super secret?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm
always nervous about talking
about content before it goes
live because what if it dates
change or anything like that.
MARK MANDEL: So
it's super secret?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It's nothing secret,
but they involve customers
and different people
working with the cloud.
So I'm like, oh, hey we got
ex President Obama on here
to talk about cloud.
And of course, I didn't.
But that would be really cool.
MARK MANDEL: That
would be really cool.
So anything you
recently released
that you can talk about?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, I think we released
two episodes earlier this month
on Stack Chat, which I think we
mentioned once or twice before,
which is kind of our
customer interview series
that I'm working on.
And one of them talks
a lot about Anthos.
And I think that's really
timely just because there's been
a lot of buzz around Anthos.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And a
little bit of confusion about
like, hey, what actually
is it and how does it work?
And I think this helps
talk a little bit
about how this
company [? Arctic ?]
found the use case for it.
And then used
Anthos to solve it.
And I think we're seeing a
lot of cool media on Anthos.
There's actually a really
fun video that Sandeep just
put out, which is a rewind
of a presentation at Next
called, Meet Anthos.
And these rewinds are fun
because they only take about
four or five minutes to watch.
And they kind of
summarize that talk.
So I definitely
recommend checking out
the Anthos episode,
the interview
with Artic of Stack Chat, as
well as Sandeep's Meet Anthos.
I guess it's not really
related to me traveling though.
So long story short,
no I'm not traveling
because we're making videos.
[LAUGH TRACK]
MARK MANDEL: No, no.
That's fine.
That's all good.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What about yourself?
MARK MANDEL: I will be at
Tokyo Next presenting, which
I'm pretty excited about.
Always love going to Japan.
And then the day before the
North American Open Source
Summit, there is an
Open Source and gaming
day where are we presenting
a couple of things.
I think actually I'm doing a
keynote, which will be fun.
So I'll be doing that.
And I'll also be hanging around
the North American Open Source
Summit, so I'll be
hanging out there.
So if you're
around, come say hi.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
It sounds like you're
heading a lot of places.
MARK MANDEL: I get around a bit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
feel like for all the
traveling you do, I
don't do, which is good
because then the Mark
equilibrium would be upset
if we both traveled or
we both didn't travel.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right,
some kind of paradox.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
you can't have us
both at the same place
at the same time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: , Well I think
that'll do it for this episode.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
I think so.
So, Mark, thank you
so much for joining me
on this week's podcast.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Bye.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]